ermittlerkreise gelernt ja leute
herzlich willkommen zum neuen video
dollar besser mit ihr gemacht und
einfach drüber gehen rüber zum zocken
heute ohne minecraft und wir sehen uns
wieder bei mir im spiel sind
so leute jetzt sind wir hier in der
runde in minecraft drei jump ich kann
euch wirklich nicht nicht sagen was da
gerade passiert ist keine ahnung
manchmal habe ich einfach so momente da
weiß nicht da passiert einfach sowas
aber ja wie gesagt viel vergessen ist
einfach was er gerade passiert ist ihr
löscht es einfach seinem gedächtnis
sollte eigentlich klappen wir spielen
heute einfach eine runde drei jump die
aber auch nicht ganz normal ist aber
leute ich kann euch leider jetzt noch
nicht sagen was heute passieren wird das
kann ich leider nicht es wird irgendwas
passieren was diese folge zu einer voll
gemacht die er so garantiert da verwette
ich mein linkes drauf und ich gesehen
hab aber ich kann euch hat jetzt einfach
nicht sagen weil ausländische mächte
mein körper kontrollieren
ja das sieht dass gerade ihm gehört auch
das war vielleicht auch der fall durch
gestellt habt
fast hört er da das war janko ich sage
euch so viel wir müssen vorsichtig hab
ich gesagt ja nicht mein charakter jetzt
habe ich die kids cult feedback vom
kameramann delden das war selbstständig
karin alt wer von euch kennt eigentlich
ein wunder caron alle schreien
ich hab euch auf jeden fall auch in der
beschreibung das lied verlinkt was ich
am anfang gehört habt und ja ich
versuche jetzt einfach möglichst schnell
hierdurch zu kommen
ok nummer eins a klassist das sieht
nicht gut aus ja okay gut aber das haben
es wieder geschafft ja ihr habt da oben
rechts leicht nummer zwei ihr seht ihr
oben rechts kartenteil nummer eins auf
nummer zwei gegangen ist erhaltet ihr
von meinem auge
da wird gleich was passieren wie gesagt
ich darf jetzt einfach noch nicht über
sprechen darf ich einfach nicht habe die
welt gleich
sollte das ist grund weswegen euch nicht
eingehalten was gerade passiert ist
red
ich bin überhaupt nicht finden es regnet
also
informierter kreise gekannt
er fragt mich wahrscheinlich
was macht wir fahren ganz leicht
erklärung aber sie kann sich jetzt steht
er ist auf jeden fall anders denkbar
es gibt für alles vertraut es ist gerade
diese einem horrorfilm von links und
rechts die ganzen leute um nachher ruft
die polizei
wieder hinsetzen das zu erklären
jetzt wird die ganze mit auch schon vom
pc weil ich wusste dass das passieren
würde sollte walter später ich weiß
nicht ob es gerade seht aber mir ist
mega warm ich habe schon noch gut
verschwitzte aus oder kämen höchst die
lage ja leute was war das gerade eben
für ein video also ich glaube ich habe
wirklich nicht zu viel versprochen als
ich gesagt habe dass ihr so ein video in
der form bestimmt noch nie gesehen habt
denn ja wo fangen wir an das war eine
challenge aber wir haben es heute mal
andersrum gemacht weil wir dachten so
mit uns meine ich mich um meinen kumpel
ali demir beim war der stelle des videos
golf hatte der kamera steht auf jeden
fall wir haben uns gedacht so challenges
gab es halt schon 1000 mal wie kann man
das irgendwie das ganze irgendwie
spannend machen wie kann man das ganze
so machen dass ihr zuhause unterhalten
seit gut bei dem video war
wahrscheinlich gehalten habe ich einfach
gedacht so was ist mit dem typen bloß wo
ist die nächste irrenanstalt wir können
ihn einweisen leute wenn ihr mich
einweisen wollte einfach eine mail an sk
ins irrenhaus at gmx.de schreiben da
könnt ihr das dann alles abwickeln so
weit aber jetzt erklärung ja wie gesagt
das war eine challenge ihr habt ja
wahrscheinlich den den timer darum recht
bemerkt der jedes mal wenn ich
runtergefallen bin 1 hochgegangen ist
also ich bin generell so gespannt auf
eure reaktion zudem videos hat noch was
ganz anderes also auch wirklich gespannt
ob jetzt sowas in der art jemals schon
mal gesehen habt wenn ja schreibt in die
kommentare und auch sehr sehr gerne euer
feedback dazu ob ihr das video hier
unterhalts anfangen also mitgefiebert ok
woran könnte es liegen testet ab jetzt
mitten in der nacht um die häuser rennt
bei regen mit einer gopro in der hand
habt euch das gedacht oder hat er
einfach gedacht okay ganz normaler tag
auf youtube
von [ __ ] aber ich bin kein folge manko
aber es gibt viele folgen youtube macht
halt wieder irgendwas komisches so
geistesgestörte scheiße 2.0 schon wieder
was waren eure gedanken bei den video
unterhalten schreibt dass auf jeden fall
mal die kommentare von jetzt zur
auflösung wie gesagt ihr habt den den
volker umgesehen und die challenge hier
hinter dem video stand die wir euch aber
nicht gesagt haben und wo es gesagt habe
okay das muss jetzt ein reiz des videos
aus dass einfach irgendwas passiert ohne
dass man weiß was abgeht war dass ich
wenn ich drei mal runter falle hier im
jump'n'run bei regen in voller
ausstattung mit der ich vor dem pc saß
eine runde um den block rennen muss und
das hieß in dem fall über mit
winterjacke und das ist eine fette fette
winterjacke sich eine fette fette party
soll noch eine fette fertig winterjacke
the fucking daunenjacke leute also da
wird einem so krass schnell warm und
dann halte man so eine kamera in der
hand ja die ganze auflösung hinter der
sache war bei der operation sprung
geschafft ich nie schaffe das ist
einfach eine an sich schon gestörte
challenge war die wir gemacht haben nur
haben wir sie noch mal gestörte durch
gemacht dass wir sie haben rückwärts
laufen lassen
also haben nicht vorne angefangen haben
gesagt ansage hat das ziel erreicht
schreiben mir irgendwann etwas ja was
soll ich sagen
das war wahrscheinlich eines der
verrücktesten ab gefragtesten videos die
ich jemals aufgenommen habe und das
obwohl ich vor kurzem schon das
verbotenen takibi ritual aufgenommen ab
was an sich schon unfassbar gestört war
aber ich glaube das ist einfach witzig
was ich mittlerweile so realisiert habe
ist dass es auf youtube einfach so wenig
bringt nachdem zu gehen was die meisten
klicks bringt und vielmehr danach was
man selbst einfach lustig findet und
machen möchte und der rest passiert dann
automatisch weil wenn man das macht
worauf man lust hat dann ist es auch am
besten die in der stimmung und die
unterhaltung ist am besten und später
gefällt den leuten einfach am besten und
ich persönlich mache einfach gerne
verrückte chance also ich hab überhaupt
keine ängste mich zu blamieren oder
irgendwas in der öffentlichkeit zu
machen und daraus ist dieses video
entstanden
es war quasi einfach nur challenge
rückwärts die challenges wenn ich da mal
runter falle muss ich mir die gopro in
der hand eine runde um den block rennen
das habe ich gemacht wir haben euch
nicht gesagt was die challenge ist jetzt
quasi erst gesehen
dann erfahren worum es sich handelt
gesagt euer feedback dazu in die
kommentare bis zum nächsten mal haut
rein macht's gut und